ryan gosling finally finished his
breakfast I'm a nice bear with her and
here at hashtag news we want to pay
tribute the man who won our hearts and
minds breath ryan mchenry the creator of
the vine meme ryan gosling won't eat in
syria passed away last sunday at the age
of 27 after a battle with you
our condolences his friends and we put
together a cut of his hilarious Ryan
Gosling series check it out
you think this is fun
well you know for a month you know we'll
get out of the way
appreciate what do you like Serio's I
love it but we can still keep feeding
these areas all the time thank you for
some funny and original videos Ryan you
made the Internet a better place you
won't be missed
click on the link to a vine account in
the description below that's it for this
edition of hashtag news hit like if you
liked this video and subscribe to new
media rockstars for all the latest
internet news and let us know in the
comment box below which f Ryan's videos
was your favorite I'm gonna use fair
weather and